notre invité ce soir cécile duflot
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
la toute nouvelle et jeune secrétaire
nationale des verts vous avez été élu il
ya moins d'une semaine vous avez vous
passé la nuit de lundi à mardi dans une
tente du canal saint martin à paris vous
souhaitez dites vous que l'on montre ce
que l'on ne voit jamais qu'est ce que
voulait dire ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est un sujet dont on parle
d'ailleurs souvent plus souvent en hiver
pourquoi en hiver parce qu'il ya des
gens qui meurent simplement de froid
mais que c'est un sujet qui doit nous
occuper toute l'année et que c'est un
vrai scandale dans un pays comme la
france d'imaginer qu'il ya des gens qui
sont aujourd'hui dans l'incapacité de
pouvoir se loger dans des conditions
dignes pour vous qui vous êtes penché
sur le dossier quand madame votre 1 10
il y a aujourd'hui 450 places
disponibles à paris et et alentours
c'est un chiffre qui vous semble
suffisant pas suffisant c'est très
difficile d'évaluer la pertinence du
chiffre parce que on sait aussi que on
met un peu tous dans le même sac et que
la question c'est pas seulement de
trouver un endroit vaguement chauffer
dans lequel on peut créer des dortoirs
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir des
conditions de vie surtout je le disais
dans un pays comme le nôtre qui soient
des conditions de vie supportable est
durable parce que on ne résout pas le
problème des sdf uniquement aux moments
les plus froids de l'année et puis le
reste de l'année on s'en lave les mains
donc nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
soit mis en place des solutions
d'hébergement durable et digne et qui
s'intéresse aussi aux autres problèmes
que rencontrent les sdf qui sont pas
seulement les problèmes du logement et
puis l'autre aspect c'est qu'on sait
aussi et c'est le cas de plus en plus
que beaucoup de gens dorment dans la rue
ou non pas domicile alors qu'ils
travaillent par exemple donc il ya deux
problèmes affectant alors cécile dufot
vous restez avec nous parce que on va
reparler un peu plus tard de politique
et de la place de la campagne chez les
verts mais d'abord on va se demander
quel rôle dominique de villepin a joué
dans l' affaire clearstream c'est
précisément cette question que vont
essayer de répondre les juges qui sont
en charge de ce dossier le premier
ministre sera entendu demain comme
simple témoin ce qui signifie qu'à ce
stade aucune charge n'est retenue contre
lui stéphane grand philippe lagoon
une visite de crèche c'était hier au
milieu des bambins dominique de villepin
souriant ne laisse rien paraître avant
son audition devant les juges je suis
heureux de pouvoir
apporter mon témoignage dans un dossier
où beaucoup mensonges et beaucoup de
calomnies ont été portés et dont je dois
dire que j'ai eu à souffrir au fil des
dernières années cette audition comme
simple témoin qui aura lieu ici au pôle
financier n'est pas sans risque pour le
premier ministre à ce stade de
l'instruction les juges jean marie d'huy
et henri pons ont prononcé quatre mises
en examen florian bourges accusé d'avoir
dérobé les fichiers à la holding
luxembourgeoise clearstream
denis robert ici à ses côtés journaliste
écrivain qui les a eu en main mais
surtout imad lahoud informaticien qui
aurait fabriqué les faux listings y
ajoutant les noms de personnalités du
monde de l'économie du spectacle de la
politique dont celui de nicolas sarkozy
enfin jean louis gergorin le corbeau
proche du premier ministre aurait envoyé
les faux listings chez les juges reste à
trouver le ou les commanditaires qui a
donné l'ordre de rajouter des noms dans
le listing les juges ont entendu des
dizaines de personnes dont jean pierre
raffarin et michèle alliot marie mais
depuis deux ans cette affaire empoisonne
surtout le climat au sein de la majorité
chez les sarkozystes on attend
volontiers des éclaircissements
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que quel
que soit le condamner celui qui ne l'est
pas qu'on soit témoin témoin assisté aux
mises en examen vraiment les français
sache véritablement avant les élections
présidentielles comment ça s'est passé
qui est responsable dominique de
villepin est attendu demain matin au
pôle financier probablement pour de
longues heures d'audition mais il sera
joignable en permanence en cas d'urgence
gouvernementale
jacques dominati est relaxé au bénéfice
du doute après 17 ans dans quête
l'ancien maire udf n'est plus poursuivi
dans la sphère des faux électeurs du
troisième arrondissement de paris qui
avait éclaboussé les
889 1995
nicolas sarkozy s'adresse lundi à la
france qui souffre qu'à cela ne tienne
ce soir ségolène royal en déplacement
dans le bas-rhin parle à la france qui
souffre de cinq années d'un pouvoir de
droite là aussi économie emploi et est
au centre de son discours sur place
catherine de mange à patrice boscher
elle arrive telle une pop star pour un
nouvel exercice un forum participatif la
mise en scène sa son émission télé doit
faciliter le débat avec la salle thème
de la soirée l'emploi et c'est
l'occasion pour ségolène royal de
répondre à nicolas sarkozy qui s'est
longuement adressée il ya deux jours
dans les ardennes à la france qui
souffre
quand on voit ceux qui sont au pouvoir
découvrir après cinq années qu'il ya une
france qui souffre mais qui souffre
d'abord par leur faute parce qu'ils ont
tout abandonné
est ce qu'il ya dans la salle
éventuellement immédiatement des
questions et les questions s'enchaînent
précarité licenciement retraite tout y
passe qu'est ce que comptent faire les
politiques et ton le ps pour augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat dans ce pays et bien
moi après une bonne heure des changes
ségolène royal décline toute une
batterie de mesures en faveur de
l'emploi elle préfère parler d'une
france qui se bat avec un état qui
sécurise
je vous le dis l'état non seulement peut
servir à quelque chose mais doit servir
à quelque chose et la puissance publique
doit assumer ses responsabilités il n'y
a pas de fatalité
la formule des débats participatifs n'en
est qu'à ses débuts le prochain aura
lieu en janvier cette fois sur le thème
du logement
le retour de l'ex lieutenant huit ans
après son divorce d'avec le front
national bruno mégret se rallie à jean
marie le pen les contours de cette
amitié politique retrouvée reste encore
à préciser pour le moment alors cécile
duflot est toujours avec nous rappelle
que vous êtes là tout nouvellement élu
secrétaire nationale des verts alors
puisqu'on parle de politique justement
où sont les verts dans cette campagne on
a du mal à vous entendre je dirais alors
que l'environnement est au coeur de tous
les programmes pratiquement des autres
candidats
on a du mal à nous entendre ou nous
écoute pas suffisamment je sais pas
tellement dans quel sens il faut prendre
la question
lui environnement et pas forcément au
coeur du programme de tous les candidats
il ya des gens qui ont une tendance
facile à donner un petit coup de
peinture verte et à penser que ça fera
oublier tout ce qu'ils ont pas fait
depuis des années dit par exemple au je
crois que un certain nombre de ceux qui
ont dit à nicolas hulot qu'ils allaient
éventuellement signer son pacte
écologique sont ou ont pas lu son livre
ou alors se souviennent pas ce qu'ils
ont fait avant-hier mais c'est vrai que
c'est une habitude sur les questions
environnementales de faire des grandes
déclarations de préférence de l'autre
côté de l'hémisphère quand ça engage pas
trop et de faire le contraire quand on
rentre en france et là les verts sont un
peu habitué à ce qu'il ya un grand
discours grand décalage entre les
discours et les actes alors justement
vous citer nicolas hulot dont ségolène
royal et nicolas sarkozy ont annoncé
leur intention de signer ce pacte écolo
finalement c'est lui qui réussit à
mettre l'environnement au coeur de la
campagne il fait partie plus que jamais
de l'une des personnalités préférées des
français est-ce que c'est pas vous qu'on
devrait avoir en première ligne sur ce
terrain il ya quelque chose d'important
c'est que nous ce qui nous importe c'est
qu'on parle d'écologie certes mais aussi
con même des politiques écologistes et
ça ça se passera j'espère d dès le
milieu de l'année 2007 ça nous semble
indispensable et on sait maintenant que
c'est quasiment uniquement quand il ya
des verts dans les exécutifs que ces
politiques écologistes sont menées et
puis parce que l'environnement la
question d'environnement c'est une
question centrale mais l'écologie c'est
pas que l'environnement c'est avoir des
réponses sur les questions
sociales et en particulier sur les
questions de la pauvreté parce que c'est
un sujet très important est qu'on ne
résoudra pas la crise environnementale
si on s'attaque pas aussi à l'urgence
sociale et on veut pas nous que ce ces
thématiques la soie sectorisé alors
c'est facile de dire que les verts on
les entend pas où il serait plus utile
le constat qu'on a comporté ya déjà
vingt ans maintenant tout le monde est
d'accord et ça c'est une bonne chose qui
que ce soit qui s'expriment sur ce sujet
c'est une bonne chose il faut une
mobilisation générale pour répondre au
réchauffement climatique c'est évident
mais si on pouvait ne pas attendre 20
ans pour appliquer les propositions
qu'on a aujourd'hui ça nous semblerait
une bonne chose merci beaucoup c'est si
tu vas l'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci